non c'est sûr de son pour cette nouvelle
et deux sur le htc mal son budget cats
est à base d'actions de téléportation
tout ça je vous parle je vous regarde
totalement pas bon bref voyez ce que je
veux dire quoi apparemment je dois
tester de prendre les choses
ouais ça nage bien et ensuite ils l'ont
fait on boit son petit café au népal et
la corse et aux attentes et marque un
truc moi tu sais quoi ça oh je vois ce
que ok en fait c'est important que j'ai
envoyée je vois deux portails la base au
caire mais là c'est ce qu'on voit de la
regarde et je ne vois là bas je sui
thomas neteven
[ __ ] c'est bien ça devient très
compliqué tout ça on se téléporte à tous
ces jeunes parce qu'en fait on est dans
une petite zone de jeu comme ça on
aimerait pécule et d'autres pièces
avaient pour apprendre un petit peu qu
au cas ou si on a des efforts on sera
pareil ouais alors cette pièce nazaire
secure ouvert en tout cas faire la paix
ça marche ou ça pour ça ok c'est génial
ja est imputable à leur secret j'ai un
couple devant ma grille lie à un tuyau
bleus qui est alimentée là bas ou alors
qu'est ce qu'on a ici
ok un coffre fort mike stern
exceptionnel c'est que j'ai fait les
vaudois alors ça c'est fermé ok il faut
une clé l'arrivée est-ce qu'on peut
éteindre ça sera fait d'acheter page 17
ok la clé là dedans
ok c'est ouvert on ouvre on va plus sur
le bouton au soleil super talent a
retrouvé à griller [ __ ] c'est super ça
dégage et l'on peut aller dedans
1 on peut juste tiré et c'est fait
[ __ ] c'est le portable nouvelle
génération white on est totalement dans
le secret c'est abusé alalala sa soeur
on va rentrer dedans on est bon cette
histoire elle sait plus du tout sur la
prémisse et abusent et aston je suis à
montpellier la chute plus sur paris
c'est quoi ça [ __ ] merde voilà hockey
[ __ ] il est juste c'est génial les
pelles d'armes tient pas dans le crochet
pour le but et je faisais lancé ça
excuse moi je vais m'excuser comme je
suis là pour son dernier tube à
entreprendre des trucs il est rangé dans
nos volontaires c'est quoi ça des
couteaux mecque le attend du coup je te
rends compte plusieurs comme ça je
pourrais les lancers [ __ ] mais bon les
gars des bons on est déjà dans ce coeur
du pop art théorie c'est d'elles l'a
achetée pas se trouver 3 c'est ça a
c'est comme d'hab avant sa retraite ou
bien dire ce poids 3 kg bombay où je
m'en vais regarder pas encore talons
hauts
c'était insein c'est verrouillé le pc je
suis toi c'est ça une carte à jouer sur
ce mec de carlos au vélo mais dès hier
ben merdès il avait il ya vingt ans je
pense que tu cet ustensile démons et
donne le noir je suis pas du lot les
attend si on lui coupe si on lui coupe
la main
savage pas du tout on va retourner là
bas et là bas on pouvait pas s'arrêter à
cette loi finalement aucun nouvel
endroit on avance en buvant du petit
café
bon et bien voilà c'est jean madaci
fonsat aux mecs mec
ok c'est paris et à marseille ça fait
comme une philosophe roi et censé paul
mouftiez dans 3 à 2 1 mais c'est ça et
c'est bien
incarnez var étaient par contre ça mais
là haut il faut une clé qu'on va trouver
et voilà vous pouvez me cacher de glycol
mec c'est comme toi tu sais quand tu as
qu'une clé pour deuil qui cache la clé
devant la maison ne fait jamais ça
surtout pas dans un tiroir
ikea open elle en est un c'est bon du
coup on va pouvoir sans titre et par là
haut ça dégage on rentre l'adorent on
est bon se plaint devant la fac il faut
être ouverte et toi tu es toi je
m'assois sur têt a perdu crier peut-être
fait trop de bruit
je t'ai tout fait mon q med faire
merde ils partent chercher le collègue
faudra taper
peut-être me mouiller ressources en eau
j'ai paniqué les personnes alors c'est
bon on est bien on est bien on est bien
on va arranger ce couteau que ça j'avais
plus de 2 ok tu te calmes
ça fait super peur avec damas je devrais
un clash mais c'est mal c'est juste pas
possible d'aller là bas
ok on a dans une nouvelle pièce d'avoir
du robot là non je crois qu'on est dans
la pièce du bois star à regarder ces
documents secrets alors est-ce qu'il
faut chauffer tout ça rien rien juste eu
des gens sous préfecture dans la
poubelle
justin louis non je peux pas choisi là
haut mais non tu crois qu'il faut aller
l'ordre il faut ce nom
mais nancy je me lève sa marche pas quoi
le foot et est ok c'est naturel dans le
conduit et ma vie c'est ça voilà je suis
un [ __ ] conduit alors à quoi on peut
aller en vo fois aux hornec berne avec
mon gars vous êtes prêt au cas où ça
attire les années je me fais tu vois là
on est pas mal en soi un sombre et
humide genre nouveau fois au [ __ ]
[ __ ] on était pas loin l'idée c'est
mon gars problèmes attendent attendent à
l'attendre je suis prêt prends garde
d'artagnan
il arrive alive
j'ai envie de buter
ils sont faits syrien où j'ai fait là
sera puni du monde ok la bad à quoi bon
dieu froisser la fin la chaîne a dépêché
trois ans qu'ils ont pour tranquilliser
sans fond je crois ça et je le 360 vous
avez terminé la démo d'accord chien bo
dont les caméras bon voyage ainsi
atteindre cette vidéo surveillance je
crois que c'est le meilleur jeu de htc
pour le moment c'est vraiment génial
j'ai totalement galal et je suis pas
plus pour atteinte au secret de kapango
non membres notamment l'agent bon voilà
je place aux as plus ces cas n'hésitez
pas les locaux de l'étude et puis on se
retrouve bientôt pour plus d'acheter ses
vibes si ça vous plaît n'hésitez pas à
me le dire en tout cas je pense vraiment
que cela sera l'un des meilleurs auquel
on doit jouer c'est sûr ben voilà +1
j'aime leur commentaire je m'apprête à
la chaîne youtube budget de corte
nous avons à la saison prochaine verra
ça me regardes et tu as tout le monde
puis je retourne regarder du porno